[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen salis welt ich
habe vor einiger zeit mal aprikosen
knödel gemacht marillenknödel und
während des drehs kam unsere die idee ok
jetzt kamen die idee magath knödel zu
machen und daraus entsteht das heutige
video wir machen heute ärgert knödel das
ganze mit einem marzipan teig denn ich
denke marzipan und nougat passen gut
zusammen
ich weiß der markt nicht so sehr aber
darin wir jetzt schon da wird schon
richtig gut und dann packen wir noch
pistazien dazu und ich finde es ganz
erinnert so ein bisschen an mozart
kugeln mozartkugel chocolat also nugat
die staats- und marzipan und es gibt
sogar mozart knödel aber ich glaube da
nimmt man die mozartkugel also dieses
süße teilchen die praline und packt sie
in der knödel rein aber wir machen seit
ganz anders also mal gucken wie wir
vorankommen wie das passiert vielleicht
frittieren bis auch wer weiß ich zeige
euch mal kurze zutaten dafür nämlich 500
gramm magerquark 150 gramm weiche butter
2 eier 100 gramm marzipanrohmasse etwas
vanille extrakt 400 gramm mehl und eine
prise salz bei der masse an rohmasse
verwende ich hier edelmann mit marzipan
stück mit mandel stückchen und es sind
62 prozent mandeln also da ist es auch
nicht viel zucker drin
daher wird datei gibt auch nicht mega
süß und ich glaube dass das pack ich mal
weg und hier müsst ihr jetzt gar nichts
beachten haut einfach alle zutaten in
eine rührschüssel doch die butter muss
weich sein dass nicht erwarten
aber das war es auch schon
zwei eier und meinen marzipan ist auch
recht weich das zerbröseln bis man kann
es aber auch einfrieren und dann ganz
einfach treiben
dann salz und mehl und die zutaten
einfach kurz verrühren
[Musik]
das war es jetzt erstmal jetzt frage ich
hier kurz auf um eine back matte und
mein gott und dann wird schon direkt g
kugel geknuddelt das klingt besser
googelt oder geknuddelt bei deshalb sei
eine art gerollt
das habe ich hier meinen lukas den
schneide ich kurz klein
eigentlich wäre es besser ich hätte nur
glücklich sein aber ich habe keine
bisschen mehl und direkt den track
auskratzen
das ist rezept so an sich recht schnell
geht das würde ich schon sagen sondern
frittieren wir probieren was sollte da
jetzt was ich brauche noch ein bisschen
mehr bei mir wahrscheinlich weil es ein
bisschen größerer an
als lukas ich versuche es mal ein
bisschen zu formen aber doch geht das
schon größer sein
nur 20 passt
wobei die stadt schon den vierten kaufen
schokolade also 25 grad in 80 gramm teig
guter schnitt
und dann zu einem knödel verschließen
also ich glaube das wird länger
doch so machen wir das okay man kann sie
aber kleiner oder größer machen aber ich
finde so ganz nett und man kann sich so
einfacher machen ihr könnt zum beispiel
diese nougat stückchen die ihr euch
abwägt formen und dann kurz einfrieren
oder den kühlschrank stellen
falls sie eben zu weich werden aber so
passt eigentlich gut
[Musik]
hier sind jetzt die fertigen kugeln ich
habe jetzt schon mal einen topf mit
wasser aufgesetzt
das darf jetzt ganz kurz aufkochen
später aber noch sehen und weil wir es
vergleichen wollen noch einen topf mit
fett
das wird jetzt erwärmt auf etwa 170 grad
und da werden wir frittieren beim
frittieren bitte immer aufpassen kein
wasser ins frittierfett geben und nicht
reinfallen lassen auch keine tropfen
denn dann entsteht eine stichflamme also
da müssen wir wirklich aufpassen ich
werde auch gleich beide separaten machen
also getrennt voneinander dass nichts
passieren kann
dann habe ich jetzt hier noch ein paar
zutaten die ich noch brauche und zwar
etwas butter semmelbrösel löffelbiskuits
und pistazien die löffel biscuit und die
pistazien einfach noch kurz verkleinern
[Musik]
meine arme ich habe pamela reife
muskelkater
ich bin gespannt was wasser und fett und
butter na los gibt noch eine kleine
prise salz zu hoch war
auch wenn es einen desserts das macht
stutzig wurde dann so ein bisschen was
[Musik]
zur butter gebe ich jetzt noch die
brösel und pistazien dann einfach gern
so ein bisschen durch röhren und mit
anbraten
ich kontrolliere die temperatur des
fettes jetzt hier über den perfect von
bosch da habe ich einfach die stufe 5
eingestellt das sind direkt 180 grad
ansonsten wählt ihr einfach etwa die
mittel hohe stufe an eurem herd oder
benutzen der friteuse auf jeden fall
sollte das fett nicht zu heiß sein aber
auch nicht zu kalt und ihr könnt testen
ob das pferd heiß genug ist mit einem
zahnstocher oder schaschlikspieß ihr
schlechten hinein und dann bilden sich
so kleine bläschen
bei mir ist die temperatur erreicht ich
hab den piepston gehört und da jetzt es
fällt zuerst bereit ist wenn man erst
coutinhos das wasser braucht noch
brauchen die überhaupt wasser sehen wir
dann
ok ich hoffe es klappt jetzt einfach und
beim frittieren müsste wirklich
aufpassen ihr dürft da auch nicht zu
viele kugeln auf einmal rein geben denn
dann kühlt das frittierfett ab und es
fängt dann an zu träumen
und wenn es schlecht läuft auch mal über
ist mir schon mal passiert als ich
schlüpfte gemacht habe also sowohl golf
frikadellen ich habe mich echt gewundert
warum das schreibt als wert spülmittel
drin und zwar wirklich weil es einfach
zu kalt wurde
und das ist gefährlich wenn dann das
heiße fett dir so in die küche läuft auf
dem parkettboden und so kam flecken
geben
es hat flecken getilgt wollen was wagen
denn erst mal rausnehmen wie lange wir
da jetzt 35 minuten
ich hoffe er ist jetzt durch komme ich
lasse mir notiert war
aber hier drüben kocht jetzt schon mal
das wasser und ich werde es jetzt
bisschen runter stellen dass es wirklich
nur noch siedet und kann bald auch noch
ein paar knödel reinlegen
[Musik]
also die im wasser brauchen jetzt so
ungefähr zehn bis 15 minuten jahrzehnt
und die im gefährt die brauchen nicht
ganz so lange also richtig schön
goldbraunen werden lassen
wer gold als frauen die eine last ich
noch und dann bin ich echt gespannt auf
den anschnitt
ich finde wir sollten den schritt friday
einführen
pretty freddy alles alles wird platziert
[Musik]
also die frittierten sind fertig sarah
drescher durch siegfried friday
aber wir werden einen freaky friday
einführen in dem wir an dem wir alles
frittieren
ich habe mir so gedacht wenn gewitter im
kopf zu mir kommt dann könnte ich
frittieren aber dann dachte ich mir so
noch zu gefährlich zu gefährlich okay
die hier brauchen wir sind also die in
der friteuse die brauchen ungefähr fünf
bis sieben minuten und die anderen
ungefähr zehn bis 15 minuten
wir probieren jetzt mal die frittierten
oder ripplinger panik die frittiert esta
fällig sie müssen zwischen hund spex
mikrofon
also da die da die frittierten nach
außen eher ein bisschen trocken sind und
nicht so nass drucken wir wert sind
jetzt trocken wir werden gar nicht
betrunken die dann niemand hat sich noch
bevor jetzt noch butter drauf wir wollen
gleich noch was ich hoffe ich finde ja
ich glaube ich wird nochmal eine soße
dazu reichen zügel nicht los
mein gott und dann so von denen und ich
habe es echt ok dass wir ne band nicht
mehr aus was auch dass die kinder das
sagen denn lukas ist halt übertönt alles
aber scheint alles gut ausgeht probiert
zu haben ich bin im team frittiert und
musste den marillenknödel gar nix
dagegen gehen richtig reflektiert es
bestanden also die vier starts wir dazu
sohn lukas und nicht zu süß
also ich finde tatsächlich die kombi mit
den löffelbiskuits super denn ansonsten
würde mir etwas zucker fehlen
frittierfett ist jetzt fertig ich hab
diskutiert noch auf als wir morgen noch
mal diskutieren wollen wir wollen also
wir werden nochmal frittieren ich werde
es nur einmal durch so ein café siebter
geben dass die teile hier wechseln und
dann kann es ruhig noch mal benutzen und
nach zwei drei mal benutzt man kritik
wird nicht mehr das heißt da gibt man es
dann abgekühlt in eine flasche und kann
es im restmüll entsorgen oder sogar
besonders sammelstelle abgeben
also jetzt wollen wir noch kurz die
nicht frittierten ihr seid eigentlich
schon mega glücklich
das war ein fehler
es war ein fehler die zu erschweren
ach komm wir geben ihnen eine chance
okay da mache ich das jetzt einfach
tropfnass direkt hier in die masse okay
ich will ich noch mal kurz kameramann
spiele kannst du das als schritt hier
als fred die experten sind immer neuer
kommt nicht ich kündige euch nochmal neu
an
[Musik]
meine damen und herren lieblinge und
panik die knödel tester das war das
bitte gerne applaus wir waren ja wohl
jetzt sagst du anschneiden während ich
noch meine knödel hier aus dem wasser
fischen auch schon mal sehr sehr gut
[Musik]
also optisch die kann schaut einfach so
so
ich wollte hat noch bis tat sind jetzt
bin ich gespannt heißt das motto des
balinger
überraschend heißt ja ich habe mir für
berufsunfähig anzeige es draußen kühl
wird man halt meine auch geld verbrannt
ich habe mir die zunge und alles
verbrannt okay dass ich war nur ein
bisschen abkühlen also was so nicht
persönlich sagen muss mehr gefällt da
bei den frittierten der krampf weil
einfach außen den kunst aber hier bei
denen finde ich tatsächlich dass man das
marzipan messerer besser schmecke ich
finde die weichen auch besser
tatsächlich wir schützen schock für alle
aber ich bin auch team gekocht das zu
dem herzen wir sind eigentlich witzig
ja aber es war eine einzige konnte aber
schmecken sie bestimmt zehn punkte
vergeben was bedeutet kommen
das aussehen von den verdiensten
vergeben wenig frittiertes 10 520
westside ist
also man kann es ja schon mal
ausprobieren ist ganz witzig aber ich
bin knödel gehören einfach in gießwasser
michael eckert mega lecker aber doch
sind die variante mit katrin und
pistazien drum rum und marzipan
ich will man sollte erst die aprikosen
kirschen und der ja alles nachspeise
definitiv also probiert gerne mal
ausgebrochen und nöte sollen frittiert
sie einfach oder kocht so wie er möchte
das rezept findet ihr wie immer in
meiner app und wir werden ich werde dir
zwei produkte weiterhin mit einspannen
und werde ihre fachlichen kenntnisse zu
rate ziehen
eppinger palik herzlichen dank bis jetzt
mal und euch viel spaß beim nachmachen
[Musik]